riya Kerry hit the stage in Mexico  Tuesday night belting out all of her  biggest hits  post-breakup with billionaire James  Packer the pop star is flaunting her  curvaceous revenge bod in this red  bedazzled bodysuit and get this she was  still wearing her engagement ring on  that all-important finger Mimi has kept  busy at work since her very public  breakup with James earlier this week new  details on the former couples prenup  were revealed apparently it dealt with  everything from what would have been  considered gifts between the two to the  use of James's private plane to how much  money Mariah would have gotten for every  year she was married to the billionaire  businessman if they divorced still a  source told ET that the relationship did  not end because of an unsigned prenup it  was because things just didn't work out  you